talking to people is just really hard  because the first time you hear somebody  who says no I think that's the world's  stupidest idea you kind of they just  don't get it  the problem is this if you're the  founder you can't ignore about 10 or 15  of those in a row and cognitive  dissidence starts setting in and smoke  starts coming out of yours because  people you're exploiting to like are  going no I think it's a dumb idea and  one or two things are actually the cases  either they truly don't get it and you  are building something they haven't seen  yet because you're in a new market or if  you're in an existing market you don't  get it and they're trying to teach you  something that you might want to pay  attention to